la recherche pour trouver un vaccin ou
un médicament contre la coved 19 bat son
plein les pharmaceutiques sont à pied
d'oeuvre l'industrie biopharmaceutique
et mobilisé comme jamais mais ottawa
s'apprête à mettre en oeuvre de
nouvelles mesures dès le 1er juillet
pour réduire le prix maximal des
médicaments brevetés
les nouvelles règles annoncé l'été
dernier vise à protéger la population
contre les prix excessifs mais elle
pourrait avoir des effets secondaires
indésirables selon l'industrie les
nouvelles mesures fédérales de contrôle
des prix des médicaments au risque
cependant de dissuader plusieurs
compagnies à mettre en marché leurs
produits au québec et au canada
en baissant les prix à un niveau comme
j'ai dit qu'ils aient vraiment
déraisonnablement bas à l'environnement
comme celui qui l'environnement canadien
où on est situé à côté des états unis ça
peut avoir un impact sur les décisions
que les entreprises vont prendre de
lancer ou d'un apollon canada annie
perreault représente les entreprises de
biotechnologie au québec demande au
gouvernement de repousser l'entrée en
vigueur de cette réforme est de
consulter le secteur de la recherche
pour éviter effets négatifs à long terme
on s'attaquait des répercussions
moindres recherche clinique ils ont fait
n'importe quoi qui est qu'il faut
baisser le prix des médicaments soient
des pleurs ou enfin ce cycle cet expert
explique que la réforme dérange les
pharmaceutiques
parce que d'autres pays pourraient
emboîter le pas à ottawa le problème
c'est que puisqu'on est le seul pays
parce que c'est la loi des brevets
indirectement qui imposerait des limites
sont épris si on estime qu'ils
fonctionnent bien somme qui risque
d'être ému les par d'autres pays le
gouvernement trudeau évaluent maintenant
la possibilité de retarder l'entrée en
vigueur de son nouveau règlement
il assure que la réforme n'affectera
aucunement la recherche surla qu'ovide
ni l'accessibilité à un éventuel nouveau
vaccin
il siffle bassan foisy radio canada